so you've finished Pokemon Scarlet or
Violet and you're wondering what to do
next well we've got you covered even
without the battle tower here are some
activities that will keep you busy for
dozens of hours technically scarlet and
Violet's story doesn't end with the
credits geta will ask you to check in on
all the gym leaders in paldea of course
a check-in means a battle and each gym
leader will hit you with everything
they've got once you've defeated all the
gym leaders for a second time you will
be able to participate in the school
tournament this allows you to rematch
your friends and teachers at top form
you'll need to do it at least once to
complete the post game story content but
you can technically participate in the
tournament as many times as you want
Additionally you can also battle team
star generals again if you return to
their bases once you've completed the
tournament Jacques will give you a call
and tell you about difficult Terror
raids popping up all over paldea do a
few of these and he'll call you again to
warn you about even tougher 6 star raids
six star raids have a pink glowing
outline on the map and can be
significantly tougher than 5 Star rates
depending on the Pokemon and its typing
when it comes to these raids I highly
recommend squatting up with some friends
or matchmaking with randoms you can
always join raids as well via the Poke
portal in the pause menu but it can be
tough actually getting into raids from
this menu your best bet is to wait until
you can refresh the raid list and join
something quickly so why should you do
all these difficult raids the rewards
for completing five and six star raids
are usually worth the trouble 5 and 6
star rates typically feature rare
Pokemon with fantastic bass stats even
if you do manage to catch one of these
rare Pokemon in the wild its stats will
be inferior you can check a Pokemon's
base stats or individual values by
pressing Plus on a Pokemon in the boxes
menu the word best next to a specific
stat means it's IV for that stat is
perfect no good means it's IV for that
stat is zero it's worth noting that you
can't see a Pokemon's IVs until you
finish the game and stopped by a Pokemon
Center doing so will unlock the judge
function along with powerful Pokemon 5
and 6 star rates could potentially net
you some rare items ability capsules
ability patches and urban mystica
ability capsules let you change a
Pokemon's ability while ability patches
let you change a Pokemon's ability to
its hidden ability if it has one these
items are incredibly useful if you plan
on putting together some competitive
teams meanwhile Urban mystica if used
properly can dramatically increase your
odds of finding a shiny Pokemon if
you're having trouble with these raids I
recommend heading back to the depths of
area 0 to catch your extramaridon or
Corydon depending on which version you
own you can technically use your ride
legendarian raids but it's nice having
an extra one in your boxes just in case
along with meridon and Corydon there are
four other legendary Pokemon you can
catch in order to crack one of these bad
boys open you need to pull eight
matching Stakes out of the ground once
you've found all eight the volt will
crumble and you can battle and catch the
legendary Pokemon if you're having
trouble finding these vaults then maybe
it's time to finish your education there
are a ton of classes you can take at the
Mesa goza Academy and completing them
will earn you some nice rewards if you
complete the history course for example
the professor will Mark all four volts
on your map of course you'll still need
to find all the corresponding Stakes to
unlock that Vault participating in
Terror rates and hunting down
legendaries will also fill out your
Pokedex if you're into shiny hunting I'd
make this a priority if you complete
your Pokedex Jacques will give you the
shiny charm which doubles your odds of
running into a shiny if shiny hunting
isn't quite your thing then maybe put
this one on the back burner if you're
looking for some more shiny hunting tips
though check out my other video on the
subject I'll drop a link in the end if
competitive battling is your thing
another satisfying time sync is Pokemon
breeding most pokemon you catch in the
wild will have poor stats the best way
to get a specific Pokemon with great
stats is through Pokemon breeding find
and catch two compatible Pokemon put
them both in your party set up a picnic
and make an egg power sandwich over time
time the basket will fill up with
Pokemon eggs typically a newly hatched
Pokemon will get a random nature and it
will randomly inherit three IVs from the
parents the goal is to hatch better and
better Pokemon which can eventually be
subbed in for the parents to produce
even better Pokemon there are a few
items that make this process easier
though a destiny knot allows the parents
to pass down 5 random IVs instead of
three from the parents and an Everstone
means The Offspring will have the same
nature honestly breeding deserves an
entire video on its own there's a lot to
it but if this is a path you're
interested in going down I highly
recommend checking out our Pokemon
breeding guide it was written with sword
and shield in mind but some of the more
in-depth concepts are still true in
scarlet and violet in the meantime I
highly recommend hunting down a five or
six star ditto raid that should net you
a near perfect ditto that you can use to
breed almost anything the story is only
the tip of the iceberg when it comes to
Pokemon games hopefully this video will
help you get the most out of your post
game Adventure in Pokemon scarlet and
violet and if you're interested in the
competitive scene I highly recommend
checking out our competitive Pokemon
explained video series on Gamespot thank
you so much for watching
[Music]